hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty we
are here in Los Angeles California at
the big show of the year I'm here with
Nick margarita hey how's it going
everybody and we have the pleasure being
joined by NFL running back Super Bowl
champion Reggie Bush are you doing so
Reggie
yeah thank you for joining kook I'm
you're too kind so forgive me for saying
it's kind of surprised to run into you
at e3 yeah what do you already up to
here well I I'm doing a lot of stuff in
eSports right now and one of the things
that we're doing this year every year I
do a charity weekend in San Diego my
hometown where I'm from and every year
we have different events multiple events
we have a golf tournament we have a kids
whole ball camp we have a fundraiser
dinner this year we added an eSports
tournament featuring FIFA so people is
one of my favorite we have any feet full
of fans here anybody played FIFA perfect
so you guys you got to check it out if
you go to Reggie Bush weekend comm we're
hosting our very first esports FIFA
tournament where all the proceeds go
towards charity so the two organizations
that we support are st. Jude's
Children's Hospital which I've been a
part of going on 1011 years now and also
a new organization called the birthday
party project which what they do is they
go to homeless shelters around the US
and they throw birthday parties for
homeless kids so it's a pretty cool
simple idea but it's a very rewarding
everything not you know the most
rewarding thing for me is we never give
back to kids so yeah you said July 16th
is when the big event you say anything
I'm bigger than you expect sorry yeah
yeah so July 16th is the event we're
hosting it in San Diego at the pin jury
hotel which is a brand new hotel and
we're doing it in their night club so
the night club is called the social the
Oxford social room okay it kind of has
this speakeasy feel to it so when you
walk in there it's kind of really cool
relaxing it's a nice environment and
we're just going to take it over and
play video games all day play people all
days yeah you were saying before that
you yourself do stream
FIFA I understand so I stream I just
started streaming on Twitch um so I
streamed FIFA on Twitch I've been
playing online you know
as long as I can remember and I remember
the times when growing up as a kid you
know you kind of look down upon by your
parents you know by playing too much
video games yeah you know they wanted
you to like get education and you know
do whatever whatever else was more
productive but you know now I feel like
this is just a great time period to be
around video games it's like video games
it's just it was taken over and you see
all the different games here III that
are but it just it's just cool man it's
just a great time to be around video
games you're talking about growing up
playing video games what were some of
the games you remember playing when you
were growing up in elementary school I
guess yeah so I played Mario Brothers I
played you know all the the sports games
Tecmo Bowl was one my favorite all Tecmo
Bowl you could be Bo Jackson and you
literally couldn't be stopped
yeah it was like this little cheat code
that you had played me a built-in cheat
code on Street Fighter Mortal Kombat I
mean I played just about every game and
I remember the I remember Sega Genesis
um I remember Sega Genesis say this is
Nintendo like all those games people are
too young to remember Sega Genesis yeah
yeah only people prior to young but um
yeah I played all those games man it was
just it was just a blast you know I
remember as a child is it was just fun
and I loved how much momentum it's
really it's really gaining over the
years these last few years the eSports
side of it yeah I was gonna say like guy
I think I expect you to play Madden more
yeah so we're expecting we were
expecting a plan it's funny because
people ask me you know when I tell them
about my maturity weekend and I tell
them I'm using FIFA people asked me why
don't you do mad and the simple answer
is because I play football my whole life
so the last thing I want to do is play
more football on video games you know so
it's funny in the NFL community in the
locker rooms we actually don't play mad
we play fifa NBA 2k Call of Duty's you
know all those all those kind of games
those are games that we play and you
know we play football all day the last
thing we want to do is go play more
football in a video game right it's just
like it's too much so it's overkill so
people for me is my biggest game
that I play right now as a player though
going back to Madden what is it like
seeing yourself in the game and in kind
of the past games do you agree with the
rating that matters you know that's what
I was going to get to you a lot of guys
feel like the ratings are are not
accurate and it feel like they can be a
lot better so you know there's a lot of
guys that you know they everybody always
checks the ratings to see if they're the
fastest person or the strongest person
right so you know for me and some of my
other friends I play with you know we've
always felt like you know we weren't
fast enough on there because just other
guys they have on it that are faster and
you like there's no way that guys faster
to me or stronger than me have you seen
much about FIFA 18 or Madden 18 or NBA
LIVE 18 or anything from the show this
week I haven't seen I haven't seen no
test out in the game yet so so I know he
is not here this year right they were
yeah they did the press conference last
weekend though like okay but they're not
here at e3 though what I mean oh they're
just showing a few things yeah thief 18
did you play 17 a lot you must know
playing 17 all right yeah um you know do
you ever play the journey like the that
story hat no I have it I just play
online and right is it yeah do I want to
get more to the story side things they
do the journey it's like it's not one
character yeah and then they're doing
like the second season that but then and
be alive as the one mode which is more
like that two story trivia Madden has
long shot which like if I was this one
kid from like high school football all
the way to Leia all the way to the
combine and the anime on online all this
stuff that's crazy because you know back
when I was playing man when I first came
out you just played it and I was it like
there was no story mode there was no
journey you know more all the different
things that you can do now especially
online like online is like the biggest
you know where you get better right for
me anyway so you know I'll be streaming
online and and I begin my butt whooped
by some little 30 old kid and like I
want to talk trash to him but no he
probably has to go bed soon his mom's
like yelling I'm in the background so
you know it's kind of cool just to know
that when you look at the age groups
right of people playing video games
there's just no there's no real limit to
it right like there's I mean there's
kids as young as like 9 8 years old that
are really good
a lot of these video games and in the
same thing we get in the 40s and 50s a
lot of older adults that are playing the
games as well so I think that more than
anything is the coolest part about video
games is that you don't have to just you
know it's not male-dominated you know
there are girls out there that play a
lot and then there's no real age you
know range as well you know it doesn't
matter your age level so that's kind of
the coolest part I think about it what
we see we see a lot of these young
people playing in these eSports events
like your events getting up a lot of
people have said they see these eSports
kind of tournaments and competitions
reaching a level where professional
sports are right now do you see that as
a possibility well I definitely see that
it's already kind of happening right
like it's like I just was talking to
some of my colleagues and League of
Legends is selling franchises and teams
like you know multi-million dollar a lot
of money right nice programs too now
yeah and you can get a college degree
now to be a gamer right so I mean out of
college when you get in college a
scholarship big gamer right so it's just
the sky's of limits right in an
individual game world and and I think
that's so cool I mean you know for me
all the love they've gotten a
scholarship playing you know video games
and I probably would've had a lot less
injuries on my knees and a lot longer
career but um you know that's that's
what's cool right is that skies are the
limits and you can do a lot with it and
I think you know hopefully someday my
kids will maybe be able to get a
scholarship playing you know video games
would you rather your son or daughter
playing sport or play video games if you
had a choice I mean just because I grew
up in sports
I would say sports but now they have
eSports so it's kind of like you know
that cross effect where you know it's
both so you know listen I think you can
learn a lot from sports in general and
and I think there's a lot you can
incorporate you know on an eSports side
that crosses over with the regular
sports side what right with hard work
dedication you know learning how to just
manage your time there's a lot of
different things that go into it and and
all those same things that you can apply
also Ally
as well so I think there's a lot of
crossover you have to go back to the
charity a little bit um how did you get
the idea to combine games and charity
you kind of touched on it but I mean
like you have a lot of different
opportunities you could bring charity
like you said you like giving back that
was it wise games why are games the best
Avenue for that from your perspective
well I think games are a great Avenue
for because when you look at right now
again like we're here at e3 you just
look at how big it is right and just
the magnitude of video games and what
it's what it's bringing to the community
and you know it's fun right and it's
cool to you know so fun and cool are two
things that I want to be associated with
I think if you can raise money in in
doing that and give back that's the most
rewarding feeling that you'll ever have
I mean right like being able to walk
down the street and hand a homeless
person five bucks or a dollar or
whatever it is is a very rewarding
feeling it doesn't matter if you know
the person needs it if they don't need
it but you know the fact that they're
out there asking for money they always
feel like they must need it more than me
right you know being able to give back
in any aspect is always going to be
rewarding feeling and then I think where
you can associate video games with that
you can associate the fun and cool
factor with that that makes for a great
event and you mentioned earlier that
among all the charity events that that
you're handling this year this eSports
event is one of the larger ones yeah so
you know when we first when I first
threw out the idea to my foundation team
about the esports tournament first of
all they don't know a whole lot about
and FIFA or or eSports so this is kind
of their first year putting this
together they were a little kind of out
of their element
now they've done a great job Lindsey's
here who's part of my foundation team
she's done a great job with Denise white
they've done a great job at really
putting this thing on and I think
capturing the moment yeah but also once
we went out and tried to you know sell
this to sponsors we were a little
surprised at just how easy it was and
how quickly people wanted to be a part
of it so we've now partnered with Ely
from Turner Sports and we partner with
Red Bull twitch is going to livestream
the whole thing LevelUp is a calm
street fighters Wednesdays they do
street fight in Orange County
yeah at the Orange County Sports Arena
so they do a street fighter tournament
every Wednesday we've also partnered
with meta meta is going to handle all
the apparel for the jerseys that we're
going to have so everybody that buys in
to the tournament gets a swag bag we
like to call it one of those swag bag is
going to be jersey apparel so meta is
going to hand all the perro in the
Nashville for the hip headset is going
to do all the headsets so we've really
partnered with a lot of great companies
that have really you know jumped on
board and and it's turning out to be the
biggest event that we have for the whole
charity weekend yeah yeah I Nick any
last questions for you wrap up no bum
we're going good i coul regimental
predictions oh boy you know you know
what we're gonna say even Giants the
charm buff I'm Paul I'm from Syracuse
but Buffalo should be my team or not no
offense but no no none taken
yeah I said you said you got a lot you
chain with Odell yeah I train what I'll
deal yes yeah yeah and administer no
deals
you know he's we were just talking about
a backstage arguably maybe the second or
third best receiver in NFL obviously the
problem is second most popular NFL
player and he's a great guy he's a
person who works hard and we love to
hear this this is great yeah yeah so you
guys got a good one on your team so
we'll see I uh what about you a Super
Bowl prediction as much as I hate to say
I think it's gonna be the Patriots back
in a Super Bowl I get back oh say that
how do you stop them what they just
again it's just getting better right now
we gotta get you on the stage right now
I just Joe alright one last time July
16th July 16th
if you guys want to sign up go to the
Reggie Bush weekend calm it's a great
cause we support two great organizations
everything is geared back towards
raising money for kids and you also get
to play fifa so that's it
awesome well everybody thank you so much
for joining we're gonna give you a slush
yeah we're gonna close it out we'll have
videos demos developer interviews all
week throughout GameSpot's III stage and
yeah thank you so much for joining us
Reggie like you for having me thank you
Nick yeah no worries se you guys for
coming you guys later see you around
thank you